[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler review of the
new Apple TV plus film Greyhound this
was directed by Aaron Schneider it was
actually written by Tom Hanks it's based
off a historical fiction novel The Good
Shepherd which was published in 1955 and
it stars Tom Hanks as Navy Commander
Ernest Krause what really hurts this
film is in its release because it was
originally scheduled to be released by
Sony in theaters it clearly is a theater
esque type movie that you'd want to see
on the big screen and because of kovat
they had to sell it to Apple so as I was
watching this film just on my TV at home
I just had to accept that this is
definitely pending the comparison of
seeing it film like this on the big
screen and that will definitely hurt the
effect of it on the audience so on paper
this is a really interesting story about
this Navy commander because it's his
first time actually leading this huge
convoy at the beginning of World War two
a battle that's not really talked about
enough for the Battle of Atlantic and
having to protect all these merchant
ships from these German submarines and
u-boats and the big conflict here being
that there is no air coverage in this
area they call the black pit and this
movie jumps right into the action you
get a little bit of backstory for like a
second with the commander here where Tom
Hanks was Elisabeth Shue you see it's
the woman he wants to marry and she kind
of rejects him and wants to make sure
that all this crazy stuff in the world
is over before they settle down but the
odd thing about this is it kind of sets
the stage for this film being a little
cheesy in a sense it kind of feels like
a 90s film and what I mean by that is
not taking place in the 90s but it feels
like it's something you'd watch made in
the 90s because there's this constant
little cheesy thing they throw in with
the him praying all the time which is
fine but none of this really has any
great payoff and even the story
introduced with the woman he wants to
marry you knew from a mile away and the
writing
that when he said when she comes around
the corner it's the greatest feeling in
the world for him you knew they were
gonna in the movie on that and her
coming around the corner so that was
strange how simple that was especially
for Tom Hanks writing it and the score
to had a lot of cheese in it and it was
kind of on repetition where you would
have oh no here comes someone attacking
and then the crazy drums kick in you get
the overhead shots and then Tom Hanks
just going in circles on this boat you
can see Tom Hanks was really concerned
about making sure the dialogue how he's
betraying how this actually was was
accurate and you see that because so
much Navy jargon is in here that it's
hard to even follow and understand
what's going on and what hurts is if you
go that route where it's so realistic
you better hope the whole environment
you're seeing visually is like that and
it clearly isn't I mean I was watching
this film and wondering why does the
water even just look so fake like the
CGI here isn't great and it takes me out
of it a lot because I never didn't feel
like I was watching a movie like I never
was sucked in so much by what I'm seeing
visually that I'm like oh my god like I
was so taken in by this whole story kind
of I just kept thinking this is a ship
in a studio lot with this fake water
around it that was really weird and it
felt like it was taking a CGI from like
a Michael Bay movie or like that
battleship movie with Rihanna and
throwing it in around a very serious
subject and historical subject and where
the writing was so focused on making it
realistic but the outside is just
another blockbuster movie it almost felt
like - with this story that it was
running on a video game timeline what I
mean by that is like it felt like it was
a mission you'd see like a Call of Duty
game even the little narrations coming
in and out from the Nazis or just from
other ships like good job captain more
food for the fish like it plays like
that and it's a just again just cheesy
and honestly I feel like Tom Hanks was
so concerned about being so accurate to
how they would be talking on a mission
like this at that time that I wish he
actually took more liberties to make
sure also that it was a little more
understandable for just the average
moviegoer and someone who wasn't totally
fluid in navy dialect and was also
concerned about keeping the story fluid
and entertaining
because the script end up just feeling
like you're reading a Navy manual and
there's no real characters here except
Tom Hanks's character I think the only
side story that worked was the one with
Cleveland who was the chef who he
actually prayed with and never ate the
food he gave him because this guy
wouldn't eat he wouldn't sleep
he was so uptight and then he noticed he
lost him which I think worked and the
whole funeral part was good but the rest
of the characters are like just pawns in
the game here they're just all walking
robots in a sense and I wish I just felt
a little more maybe had some other
characters have some kind of attachment
to you as the audience member and the
movie is only an hour and a half which
is pretty rare for something that's
based off history and it kind of feels
like a war movie that just keeps all the
battle sequences in and cuts out the
rest
it's strange in that sense maybe there
is an audience for this though I think
there's a lot of people like this movie
if they're really into action and I
think all the action sequences work I
really actually like the sound design
and the sound mixing I felt all of it
even on my TV screen so that says
something and it feels like a movie that
when you were a kid let's say you watch
movie Titanic what I would do is I would
fast-forward through the adult dialogue
and and content and then just go to the
ship sinking part and watch that I think
this felt like someone took a longer
film or film took out all those parts
about character and just threw in the
action so I definitely think those
people are gonna enjoy it for that and
just want it for that they get to see
Tom Hanks running around and all these
explosions cool but the end the day it's
not a great film its handling half the
battle here in making a good movie but
leaving out the rest and I'm trying to
say that I'm biased too because I really
do love action films and I just think
that if they just tweak the little
things here it could have been much
better and just put a little more effort
into the characters especially even Tom
Hanks's character cuz you only set up
the thing with his wife and that he's
new at this which was cool and that he's
just and he's got to make decisions that
he's not even so sure about and they
cast it around him well with just you
know these babyface type guys so it also
showed how young some of these people
were during that time in war but it
and it just felt lazy and just coming
around with all those abbath shoe at the
end I don't know I didn't really do
anything for me probably didn't play
better is just a video you throw on in a
history class to just show a battle and
this is historical fiction story but if
you're going off something old or - you
can't get obsessed with making it so
accurate and I think Tom Hanks did I
think he was he must have been a little
worried that Oh someone's gonna think
I'm taking too many liveries but that's
part of the game here in moviemaking
right so I think some points you have to
do that it's inevitable to make sure
that your audience is still engaged if
you want to see a great movie with Tom
Hanks on a ship watch captain Phillips
instead that has it all or this just has
some so I think a fair score for this
film would be a five point eight I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it down
below maybe you loved it maybe you hated
it I read every comment try to respond
as many as I can and please make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss one of my
movie reviews I also do TV reviews and
celebrity interviews as well I can use
any subscriber I can get and please
follow me at Steve rd1 on Twitter
Instagram for more of me and I'll see
you next time